the mcu may be home to whole armies of
heroes and villains but some of marvel's
most popular characters have yet to
cross over into kevin feige's epic
franchise
but why here are the real reasons we
haven't seen these marvel characters
show up in the mcu
also known as the silver surfer noren
rad is one of marvel's more deeply
tragic heroes
in order to save his homeworld from the
planet devouring galactus
rad agrees to become the villain's
herald searching the space ways for
other planets to sate galactus's
never ending hunger he later stands up
to galactus in order to save the earth
and is forced to confront the
immeasurable death and destruction he
has enabled as a herald
silver surfer made his live-action debut
in the 2007 bomb
fantastic four rise of the silver surfer
a year before the mcu was born
there were widespread rumors that the
space hero would make an appearance in
2018's infinity war too but as it turned
out both
infinity war and endgame came and went
without any sign of the surfer
the first and most obvious reason for
surfer's mcu absence is that until
disney's acquisition of fox marvel
studios just didn't have the right to
use him
while the acquisition began in 2018 it
wasn't finalized until march 2019
so in most likelihoods silver surfer is
going to have to wait in line until
after the introduction of the fantastic
four
unless marvel studios plans to
drastically change his origin
silver surfer can't be introduced
without galactus and while galactus
could be featured without the fantastic
four it seems pretty unlikely
since galactus is very much tied to
their story think of it this way
introducing the silver surfer to the mcu
outside of fantastic four film would be
like
premiering loki outside of thor or
introducing the red skull in a
spider-man flick
no first family no server that's the
deal
to the fans of marvel comics one of the
most conspicuous absences
from the mcu's infinity saga was the
cosmic savior adam warlock
warlock is referenced a couple of times
in the films including making a kind of
cameo in guardians of the galaxy volume
2's mid-credits scene
i think i shall call him
adam so far however warlock is pretty
much a no-show
in fact despite the big hint dropped in
the second guardians film writer and
director james gunn has gone on record
to say
adam isn't a lock for the third film
warlock is one of the most
pivotal figures of the 1991 miniseries
infinity gauntlet
from which infinity war and endgame take
much of their inspiration
in fact after the events of infinity
gauntlet it's adam warlock who takes
ownership of the infinity gems and forms
the infinity watch to help him
responsibly act as steward to the
powerful artifacts
while warlock's absence from the
infinity saga is regrettable it's
understandable too
warlock's prominence in infinity
gauntlet is based on a long history of
conflict between warlock and thanos
but when the mcu's thanos struck in
infinity war
all we'd seen of adam warlock were
easter eggs bringing warlock into that
already crowded film would mean making
time for another origin story
regardless of the source material the
time just wasn't right for warlock
here's hoping fans will finally see him
in action in the third guardians film
once disney's acquisition of fox was
announced a lot of fans seemed to think
the x-men's mcu debut would come
relatively quickly some even posited
theories about the mutants being
introduced in
endgame unfortunately it seems like
it'll be a while before the x-men take
their place in the mcu
marvel unveiled their plans for phase 4
at the 2019
san diego comic-con with no x-men
related projects among the announced
films and tv shows
and this was before the kovid 19
pandemic pushed back theatrical releases
for
all the major film studios part of the
problem is that marvel studios has done
well
playing the long game and they're not
going to start rushing anything anytime
soon in april 2019 kevin feige told io9
that the next five years of mcu projects
had been mapped out before disney's
acquisition of fox
making it unlikely marvel's uncanniest
heroes would be introduced before those
five years were up
if you find that news frustrating you're
not alone in may
2020 deadpool creator rob lyfield made
headlines after publicly doubting that
deadpool 3 would ever happen
lyfield told io9 inside sources had
assured him there was no movement on
either deadpool 3
or on any of the x-men properties at
marvel studios
so although it seems inevitable that the
x-men will show up in the mcu eventually
it doesn't seem like it's going to
happen anytime soon
disney's acquisition of 20th century fox
also opened the doors to bring marvel's
first family home
while the team aren't marvel's first
superheroes 1961's fantastic four number
one is the comic that paved the way for
the company's success
and drastically changed the comic book
industry altogether
you could argue that an mcu without a
fantastic four is like a dc eu without a
superman or a batman
so far however there's no firm word on
when we'll see the fantastic four in the
mcu
or if they'll premiere in their own film
or someone else's
among the more popular rumors are the
casting of john krasinski
as reed richards as well as the
intriguing fan theory that the team
could premiere in ant-man 3 with the
team being stuck in the same quantum
realm
where hank pym found janet van dyne in
ant-man and the wasp
honestly though it would be a surprise
to see a new fantastic four movie as
part of the mcu anytime within the next
few years
on one hand there's the simple fact that
no fantastic four projects were part of
marvel's face for announcement
on the other marvel studios will likely
want to make sure the time is right for
their iconic quartet
there have been three fantastic four
films in the 21st century two of them
were bombs
and none were critically successful
there's no way feige is going to rush
into something as important as this
namor the submariner is one of marvel's
earliest heroes
the aquatic hero first shows up in
1939's marvel comics number one
and his subsequent battle with the
original human torch is often considered
the moment the marvel universe was
created
since it established that two heroes
from two different comics could exist in
the same narrative
the main reason namor hasn't shown up in
the mcu is mostly to do with film rights
universal studios acquired the film
rights to naymore in the 90s
it's not known exactly when it happened
but in 2014 marvel studios president
kevin feige confirmed that the film
rights to the submariner had at some
point reverted back to marvel
the situation is still complicated
though no one has confirmed it but it
seems likely that namor's situation is
similar to the hulks that is while
marvel studios may have the film rights
to namor
universal still holds the distribution
rights this means that just as with the
hulk
marvel could include namor in a team-up
movie but not his own solo film
it's seemingly more and more likely that
neymar is on the way though it will
probably be a while before anyone knows
for sure
there are some persistent rumors that
namor will be the villain of the
upcoming black panther 2.
and in april 2020 avengers endgame
co-writer christopher marcus confirmed
the mention of an underwater earthquake
in the film was a reference to namor
do we have a visual how are we handling
it nat
it's an earthquake under the ocean we
handle it
by not handling it whether this pays off
however has yet to be seen
also known as wonder man simon williams
actually almost had a cameo in guardians
of the galaxy vol 2.
for the scene set on earth firefly star
nathan fillion posed as the actor turned
hero in movie posters advertising
a simon williams film festival sadly no
shots of the posters made it into the
finished product
there are a few good reasons why this
ionic-powered avenger has failed to show
up in the mcu thus far
for one thing one of the big comic book
moments he's best known for is being
involved in ultron's creation of the
vision
and that already happened in age of
ultron without wonder man's involvement
for another he has a reputation for
being a little derivative
his name sounds too similar to the more
well-known wonder woman and his power
set and physical appearance makes him
seem
kind of like a superman knockoff finally
there's simply been no great clamor for
wonder man's introduction to the mcu
and he's never been perceived as much of
a marquee character
there was a wonder man one shot in 1986
though as well as an ongoing solo series
in the 90s and the 2006 to 2007
miniseries
so that's not to say it couldn't happen
after all neither black panther nor
guardians of the galaxy comics were
breaking sales records before they
became movies
but for the time being it looks like
wonder man is staying firmly off
marvel's radar
there have been a number of different
incarnations of the thunderbolts since
they were introduced in the 90s but the
common thread is that the team's lineups
are
almost always made up of former or
current bad guys
or heroes who prefer more lethal tactics
things looked bright for a thunderbolt's
entry into the mcu when james gunn said
that he'd made it known to kevin feige
that he wanted to make a thunderbolts
film
but so far the team has yet to make an
appearance
there are probably a couple of reasons
for that since the interview in which he
said he pitched the thunderbolts
gunn was fired from guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 for offensive tweets from
years earlier
hired by warner brothers to write and
direct the suicide squad and eventually
rehired by marvel
so if gunn planted any seats for a
thunderbolts film they would have likely
been uprooted with his initial firing
not to mention that 2016 suicide squad
and the upcoming the suicide squad
prominently features super villains
acting as heroes so it could be that
marvel is apprehensive about being seen
as
ripping off their distinguished
competition but you never know
while marvel hasn't announced any
upcoming thunderbolts movies there are
rumors the team will be featured in the
upcoming
the falcon and the winter soldier disney
plus miniseries
and considering varen zemo the
thunderbolts original founder and leader
still has a role to play in phase 4
and beyond well let's just say never say
never
in marvel comics one of the most
powerful members of the avengers is
hercules the super-powered strongman of
greco-roman myth
physically he's in the same class as
marvel powerhouses like thor
and the hulk and just as he does in his
legendary stories
he often finds himself in conflict with
the gods who make up his family
hercules is an infectiously fun
character too
and ironically many of the ways in which
he's most fun offers some insight into
the most likely reason for his absence
in the mcu
he's overconfident party's hard and
often sees himself as the god's literal
gift to women
he also tends to think with his fists
has vicious rivalries with his siblings
and never listens to his extremely
powerful father who happens to be the
leader of the gods
in other words you can easily make the
argument that if you want to see a
hercules movie
you could easily just watch the first
half hour or so of 2011's thor
whether he's redundant or not it's
possible hercules could debut in the mcu
in june 2020 the cinema spot claimed
that unnamed sources had revealed
hercules was on his way to a live-action
marvel studios project
there was no indication of whether this
would be a team-up film or one of disney
plus's marvel miniseries or whether he
would appear in his own project
marvel has offered no confirmation so
far but
it's not like they would is it check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one